hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 11 of his book the selfish
gene
richard dawkins asks an age-old question
that
has been massively central in philosophy
and also in other
related fields are human beings
on some basic level fundamentally
special and differentiated from the
other things that we call
animals or from life more broadly
speaking
and very often the answer that
philosophers have given is something
like yes we're the rational animal
dawkins isn't so worried about that and
he's not going to focus
in on that in this chapter as what does
in fact not completely but in a really
significant degree
separate us off from the other animals
he's going to say
in a word it's something different
culture
cultural transmission and even
evolution is going to be something
central to this kind of being that is
human being this kind of
animal the question then is is this
unique to humans and he says no it's
it's not unique
he brings up the example of birds he
says
the best non-human example i know has
been described
by jenkins as the song of a bird called
the saddleback which lives
on islands off of new zealand on the
island where he worked there was a total
repertoire of about
nine distinct songs any given male
saying only one or a few
of these songs and the males could be
classified into dialect groups so
and he gives some examples here
different dialect groups sing different
songs so
this is something that many of us who
have listened to birds and have traveled
across the country or can be familiar
with it's not just saddlebacks there are
other
birds that sing different songs you can
even sometimes participate in them for
example
when doves are engaging in their song
you can
you know add a note to it and get them
to add a note
and there's there's a quite complex
array of songs now what what dawkins
brings up is the fact that
every once in a while the songs would
change and
the new song originally
tweeted i suppose you would say not
saying by
the bird perhaps of even a mistake or an
aberration some sort of mutation would
get picked up by other
birds and it would now become part of
the repertoire and you could associate
it with different
dialects very interesting right he also
talks about
uh as examples here um
you know he says song in the saddleback
evolves by truly non-genetic means
there's other examples of cultural
evolution in birds
and monkeys and then he says something
really important here
but these are just interesting oddities
these are not
absolutely central to the
mode of existence and the way in which
things develop for those species and you
know
maybe that's a little debatable but
we'll put that to the side
it's very clear that with human beings
culture is absolutely central to us
and he goes on and he says
it's our own species that shows what
cultural evolution
can do language is only
one example out of many and it gives a
whole bunch of others
fashions in dress and diet ceremonies
and customs
art and architecture engineering and
technology
these are examples and he says that
you know we also have to point out the
vast diversity
of this he says we have to be able to
explain the
immense differences between human
cultures around the world from the utter
selfishness of the ick
which is a really recent phenomenon uh
they're a tribe that was studied by an
anthropologist in the 20th century after
going through a terrible
catastrophe uh to the gentle altruism of
margaret meads
are arapesh so how do we
explain the fact that there are all
these
interesting cultural manifestations that
develop that get passed on can we
explain this
solely on the basis of genetics
and his answer is no he says these
evolve
in historical time and evolve very
quickly if we think about
for example recent musical trends
uh you know if we think about rock and
roll rock and roll
is actually not that old and some of the
people who were involved in
innovating within it and creating genres
such as for example classic heavy metal
rock and roll really hadn't been around
that long when they are evolving it
like that so he says that all of these
evolve in historical time in a way that
looks hot like highly speeded up
genetic evolution but has really nothing
to do with genetic evolution
so that's that's quite interesting
if that's the case then how do we
explain it here's where he says that
a proper darwinist perspective
would have to go beyond what we might
call reigning dogma
of darwinism which it tries to focus
on the biological organism as such
and and genes as the thing that carries
that
so focusing on biological advantage of
cultural matters dawkins thinks is
actually
misguided he says that
tribal religion has been seen as a
mechanism for solidifying group identity
valuable
for a pack hunting species whose
individuals rely
on cooperation to catch large and fast
prey frequently the evolutionary
preconception
in terms of which such theories are
framed as implicitly group selectionist
but it's also possible to rephrase the
theories in terms of orthodox
gene selection and he says listen maybe
some of this
actually does work but it doesn't
do much to explain the proliferation and
differentiation and evolution of human
culture in historical times
so the people who want to trace it just
to genes the people who want to talk
just about group
selection this isn't really conveying
what we need and it's not really
scientific you could say it's
essentially pseudo
scientific so dawkins
suggests going back to as he calls it
basic
principles and by this we could say he's
actually looking for some basic
principles
and saying we need to engage in some
real inquiry
put aside the reigning dogmas and ideas
that everybody knows and let's think
about this
in a serious way and i would say that
this makes it you know properly
philosophical in in an important way
so he says that these ideas that we have
are plausible
but they don't begin to square up to the
formidable challenge of explaining
culture cultural evolution and the
differences between
these cultures i am an enthusiastic
darwin darwinian
but i think darwinism is too big a
theory to be confined
to the narrow context of the gene the
gene
is not the sole basis for ideas
of evolution particularly cultural
evolution
and he says that the gene can at best
provide us with an analogy
for a unit of cultural evolution and
transmission
that which he's going to call the meme
right
and we should stop here for a moment
think about what analogy means
so analogy is somewhere in between
university saying that these are the
same thing the word refers to the same
thing
evolution in both cases is the same
process
and complete equivocity where we say
well these things are not really related
to each other at all
there's some sort of connection some
sort of mapping
that's possible but it's a bit more
loosey-goosey
and we need to look at things more
carefully we don't want to
treat an analogy as if it's a blueprint
we want to think about it as an
opportunity for thinking matters
through so the gene can provide an
analogy
for this unit of cultural evolution
and transmission how well he says
let's ask a really basic
fundamental question what is so special
about genes why do we care about them
why do we talk about them in the first
place
it's not because we want to like you
know create a hierarchy and discriminate
against people people do that with genes
right stupidly but that's not what
people who are serious about studying
genes are doing
it's not just so we can make a ton of
money you know fusing
genes from one you know animal or you
know
species in general into that of another
with biological engineering no no
we want to actually understand in this
way what
what makes jeans genes and the answer he
says
is they are replicators
now this raises some really interesting
points
right there could be other types of
replicators
what if we went to an alien planet and
we discovered that instead of being
based on
carbon they were based on other
elements silicon you know this happens
in sci-fi
stories right but what if that was the
case
or what if they instead of using oxygen
use
methane can we consider these sorts of
things they might not have
the dna molecule they might have some
other mode of replication
he says um the
the gene the dna molecule happens to be
the
replicating entity that prevails on our
planet there may be others
if there are provided certain other
conditions are met they will almost
inevitably tend to become the basis for
an evolutionary process
when we are speculating about artificial
intelligence
replicating itself we're talking about
things that are not
genetic but rather based on
a computer code right and so
he draws a conclusion
from this he says do we have to go to
distant worlds to find other kinds of
replicator and cons
and other consequent types of evolution
and the answer is no so we should think
about two things before that
for a long time dna was
the main type of replicator as a matter
of fact
throughout the long history of life
except for a tiny little blip
at the end uh some people are calling
the anthropo
anthropocene right the era that where we
are dominating the planet
as best as we can we're certainly
determining a lot of important things
about it
dna was the main replicator it still is
for our bodies
that's absolutely central but it's not
the only replicator
and we need to think about and we're
going to come back to this in a moment
what is it that that
replicators actually have or do what
qualities make them replicators
before that though he says
a new kind of replicator has recently
emerged on this very planet it's staring
us in the face
it is still in its infancy still
drifting
clumsily about on its primeval soup
right there's part of the analogy to
the soup that produced dna but already
it's achieving evolutionary change at a
rate that leaves the old gene
panting far behind the new soup
is the soup of human culture
there's a little bit of circularity here
that i think we have to be
careful of because what is culture well
culture itself is filled up with these
new kinds of replicators
what is the new soup well it's that of
of culture
so which came first the chicken or the
egg let's think about this more
in terms of dialectics and put that
question aside for a moment and come
back to
something really important what makes
something replicators
so earlier on in the book dawkins
brought out three key features longevity
they will remain around for a while
they're not just
like you know well i mean even animals
that only
exist for a day and then die off they
have dna right
but uh they're they're part of a long
process
and in general genes can survive for a
long time
and the new kind of replicator that he's
talking about here
cultural transmission can as well
fecundity
reproducing themselves in significant
numbers
so that they can spread and then compete
against each other
or you know find out other relations
with each other
finally copying fidelity which means
that as you're
self reproducing as you're replicating
you're not introducing a lot of noise
compared to signal you're preserving
something that's identifiable if not as
a philosophical essence at least as
a stable configuration for the most part
and dawkins thinks that the units of
cultural evolution and transmission
that he's going to talk about as memes
in fact
fit this bill now one thing that we
should point out at the very end of this
is this really a radically new theory on
dawkins part
or is he rediscovering what other
thinkers other theorists have done in
other fields
it's really the latter this is not a
radically
new ideas a matter of fact you can find
it brought up in
sci-fi by various people you can find it
in other fields such as say
semiotics or you know study studies
other studies that are connected with
the language and
culture but dawkins very helpfully coins
a phrase
and frames this in his you know
darwinian context so
and and i think it's quite useful to
think about this analogy part of the
the issue as well is this shows us that
there would be genetic evolution on the
one side
and then there would be cultural
evolution and there can be connections
between them
but they are distinct from each other
rather than
one being reducible to
the other as many other
theorists of these matters have tried to
argue
you